In case you missed it, we're moving again.
Heading back to Connecticut to go house hunting for the second time.
After looking at a few houses a couple months ago,
we just needed to look at a few more.
After our job in New York,
we decided to just head out there for a couple days.
We woke up bright and early.
I had some tea, took my vitamins,
journaled before it was time to get dressed myself.
It's actually getting quite chilly,
which I'm really excited about.
I opted for something comfortable
while lucky packed up all of our bags so we could get ready to go.
Since we were running late,
lucky packed up the car pretty quickly
before we headed out to Connecticut.
I never knew how much traffic we'd encounter, though.
It actually ended up taking us
two and a half hours to get to Connecticut,
which gave me plenty of time to do my makeup in the car
and respond to all the emails that I've been missing.
The drive was so beautiful.
Seeing all the trees change color
made me excited to live here during the fall.
And lucky and I are so picky with our houses.
We're looking for something that has really good bones
and a lot of potential
that we would eventually fix up and change a few things.
Trying to convince lucky still to get some chickens.
We're already planning everything we're gonna plant in our garden.
We also went back To see one of our favorite houses
that we viewed last time we were in Connecticut,
and we still love it as much as we did the first time.
There's something I enjoy a lot about an indoor pool.
I love that feature about this house.
After two more days of elaborate house hunting,
I think we found the house that we love.
I can't wait for this journey and to show you guys more.
But for now, we're heading back home to Texas.